foreign
look I know we had the work today and we
didn't really get to sleep but
whoa
let me make it let me make it up to you
in a little way right
[Music]
yeah I love my mother
hate my brother
so let's get after it
and have us
I would [__] break okay
so
good news is he's we have a video of him
Chris said he was going to start taking
calls and stuff where we could call in
good news is we have that video I
skimmed through it and I don't think
that any of our people got on but
I think it's still it's still worth
playing here hold on let me pull it up
two you got to chill the [__] out
I know you haven't seen me but you gotta
calm down yeah dude my cats are [__]
annoying today
bear your Independence be a critical
agent free agent critical thinker the ad
all goes together it all goes together
that's why you need the gear to keep it
straight listen if you call I'm going to
take your calls and we're going to
answer as we can if you send comments
we're going to go through them and get
back to you as we can why because this
because you need interaction for your
YouTube channel
you need yeah that's what it is you need
interaction
now he he's getting accused of something
here hold on here you go on the most
recent youTube comments episode somebody
also wrote this is from matt22 this
ocean of positive comments reminds me of
Bill Maher's podcast comment section two
guys with Deep Pockets employing click
farms and anything else to keep their
sinking Enterprise relevance yikes
it is kind of weird that our clips of
him disappeared a bit huh yeah it's a
little weird Chris I know you're paying
one of these MCS one of these little
firms one of these media management
firms yeah
maybe this is just me Rob you like that
[__] I hope they rob you like Ethan
Klein Chris yeah because I'm selecting
these comments these weren't all the
most positive comments I think I think
you actually get a fair amount of
pushback on these pages and and positive
comments because people like the stuff
you put up but people also want to weigh
in look I I've said it many many times I
really do think you have to
think before you speak
balls on this guy
Chris Cuomo
of course Cuomo just said you need to
think before you speak oh God excuse me
Chris Cuomo just said hey you guys you
know the thing is some of your loud
mouths
okay
negativity really should have thought
about it before you said that yeah
should not be a proxy for insight I I
really I hear that comment and all I
hear is somebody wanting to take
somebody else down you didn't answer the
question Chris
but see you notice that
are you using a click form
but without any really good reason why
and by the way I don't think he's using
a click Farm because if he was he'd be
getting more than 5 000 views in five
days
no yeah he's definitely not [__]
paying for views hey Chris you ever
wanna probably he probably does have a
management firm that's you know
sanitizing his page though hey Chris you
ever want to come on a bigger show you
let us know bud oh have you on yeah
we'll help you out buddy we got you I
mean you know if we have you on the show
it's not going to show up in the
algorithm because you made a phone call
but it doesn't matter it's still more
popular than you and
if nothing else you should think about
well if I'm able to think that and I'm
sure a lot of other people will take it
the same way I am because I don't really
care one way or the other you know what
I mean you can criticize whatever you
want
but
if you don't have cogency
and you don't have decency
then what do you have you screamed at a
biker you screamed at an old cyclist
yeah you threatened your neighbors
now here's a fun one and this one I
think might be ours because we we point
this out a lot I just I haven't heard it
but I I'm just you know has a little you
could like click uh the topic so let's
sit here this is from a recent walk and
talk where you're wearing a free agent
hat one of the ones that we sell here on
the channel uh this is from automated
teller machine 1995. that hat that says
free agent is a cry for unemployment he
looks like a permanent Park camper
also uh sir that's a good line
also producer
that does that guy's name is not
automated teller machine like it's it's
ATM it's just ATM I I dude sir there are
other like
ATMs that aren't I'm not going to get
specific but you know
there are other
acronyms that you could spell out with
ATM just putting it out there sir how
come you didn't say yeah we got a
comment from ass to mouth 1995. what's
going on see what he's doing
and Gail Bennett writes Chris guys take
the stickers all of them off your hats
okay that's we've been pointing these
out now
second comment first if you've seen
multiple people with the stickers on the
hats doesn't that tell you that maybe
you're missing something no
he's saying he's saying it's cool hit
hip yeah for a 20 year old black guy not
for a guy pushing 60.
dude did you hear but but he thinks that
because no no hear me out
he thinks that because how old's Chris
Cuomo okay
while I'm looking hey Google how old's
Kris Cuomo
he's he's 52 52. boom
We're Not Gonna fire you for
underperforming we would have done that
months ago yeah seriously when you show
up
um so you see oh right now you're in
danger yeah
a 52 year old man going like oh if
you're seeing other people with stickers
on their hat doesn't that tell you
something yeah that you're a bunch of
[__] lemming [__] is what it tells
me Christopher that's what it tells me
that you're [__] out of touch 52 year
old man who's trying to act like he's a
20-something year old man I don't give a
[__] by the way I've done way past
trying to be Vulcan hip I don't care
whatever it's comfortable I don't give a
[__] I've kind of already leaned into my
style that's fine with it but like I
don't understand being like at 52 right
why would you still be evolving you know
evolving your style like you know what I
mean like merch you know like like your
parents right when they reach a certain
age that's that they've bought their
outfits for the rest of their lives like
that's what they're wearing and that's
their thing yeah if my like if my dad
showed up with an unbent Rim hat like
because he thought I'd be like are you
okay you know yeah and if I wanted to
start dressing like a wigger again like
the only way to go back and do that
gracefully at this age is to go back and
dress like the wigger I was you can't
dress like the new wiggers because you
just look silly Marshall's a bunch of
[__] Sean John velor sweatsuits be
like all right he looks like an [__]
but at least it's age-appropriate I was
gonna say Mark Echo I was getting lazy
that's fine I was gonna say Mark Echo
okay so that's if I went back to my wig
my wigger face I'd be wearing South Pole
South Pole and lugs
remember lugs
um well no I mean I'm from New York so
you know [__] with lugs but I get it
[__] Wu-Tang
you can't be caught dead Island uh Chuck
Norris Sun Club Chris Cuomo's RTC
interview hype train
yes you are a lot of hobbyists to
collect gear
want oh you're on gear
prison labels and tags on them because
it increases their value but not if
you're wearing it yeah not if it's a
Chris Cuomo free agent shirt from
Redbubble
like we're not talking about a special
edition hand signed [__] Michael Kors
something or other no it's not it's not
you're right it's it's not a it's it's
not it's not a hat that Nolan Ryan wore
in the [__] and Ryan were in the [__]
in in the in the World Series like good
point
Chris they just slapped the word by the
way it's not even a particular cool
style it's just a word free an agent
yeah I mean the only hat anyone has sold
that made me remotely like collectible
someday are the Medicare hats and they
won't be because he doesn't really have
cancer so I mean like Chris learn
something from this yeah you gotta Stop
Printing [__] for it to be worth money
yeah exactly and it also has to be a
design that isn't just white block
letters and I could easily steal go on
the same Drop Shipping website and make
myself and by and by the way Virgie the
same goes for money you have to stop
printing it for it to be worth money
that's true and that's what we're doing
to not be one of them I had the stickers
on the hat because I thought it was
funny
but I thought you said it was look good
it was cool what's the joke I mean
besides you and your news and [__]
Mac Show news Nation show whatever the
[__] it is dude he just did the classic
blunder here
he did the classic like this is the
thing I see so many times with people
that want to be funny and want to do
he's he's he front loaded with yeah dude
you maybe notice a lot of people do it
because it's trendy and cool now and
then I did it as a goof though I did it
because it was funny I like I think
they're no you didn't no the problem is
is that and by the way I know it wants
to be cool and funny
um
hip Cool Chris
and I like to give people like you
something that bothers them that I find
completely irrelevant Yeah it's you're
living rent for you wait you're wearing
the stickers he's trolling us no no but
you're right but you're wearing the
stickers on your hat
first off you had those on your hat
because you thought they were cool you
said it earlier now you're saying you
wear them to troll people you're doing
it to piss people off
okay first off even the people that are
talking about it they're not calling you
names or anything they're just mildly
making fun of you like it's really mild
like we we we make funny a lot worse
Chris and that's why you probably helped
take us out of your algorithm
um
but Chris I gotta tell you what you know
what's gonna happen you're getting
really really irrelevant and here's
what's going to happen my prediction you
ready all right Royster Thomas here you
ready within a year he's going to be
playing our Clips or talking about our
show because he's going to need us
because yeah no no but but look he's not
growing his Channel's not growing it's
kind of stagnant you know like who gives
a [__] about Chris Cuomo's hats
now as to the other comment
about free Asian is like a cry whatever
that is again if you're going to be
nasty you got to get your hate straight
your game's got to be strong
well then guess what we're your huckle
bee because we're real good at it I'm
your huckle people yeah
we're really good at it
and you have to Target it in a way that
using you mean like you mean like the
way your brother targeted female state
employees hey look at my sausage oh yo
you want to grab my gabagool okay yeah
Darkness
points at something that is a
sensitivity you failed on all fronts
okay I'll point to something that said
uh um to quote Star Trek he tasked me
okay let's see what's a sensitivity the
fact that you have hypertrophy testicles
because you've been on [__] gear for
so long that they don't work anymore and
even if someone put a gun to your head
you couldn't pump another [__] kid
out or is it the fact that you got fired
from it from a from a net from a network
that's doing so poor that only empty
Airline seats watches them and you still
weren't worth up to the task of that
yeah or is it the fact that you and your
brother are both the or your dad was in
the [__] Mafia and you two are more
disgraced than he was because at least
he made it through a [__] full term
as Governor how about that Chris how
about we all see the hair plugs you're
doing we're not [__] fooling anybody
how about you can't afford the botox
like you used to on TV that's why the
wrinkles are on your [__] head way
more how about you're such a [__] out
of touch [__] Guido that probably
goes to these [__] clubs and cheats
on his wife because you these young bras
but it's not happening anymore because
you're not on TV anymore right Chris is
that what's happening how does that
sound did we hit a [__] spot huh how
does it sound Chris is still going out
and picking up these like [__] you
know 30 something 20 some year old
[__] getting back to his hotel and
his dick just isn't working yeah it's
not because you [__] you you
destroyed your endocrine system with too
much [__] gear you [__] [__]
your Guido spaghetti eating [__] how's
that is that hitting a little [__]
closer to home the home that you're
[__] hoping is paid off because you
don't got that CNN money anymore and it
let's face it you [__] you might you
might be Italian but you spend money
like a sicilian if you catch my [__]
drift okay so let's [__] come back is
that closer to home Chris Chris I think
I'll have one of those Chesterfields now
um
this [__] guy is unbelievable he
really wants to be cool and funny at the
same time yeah but yeah Let's Dance
Chris come on hey I got some for you
Chris
Don Lemon oh still has a job at CNN
that's right not only does he have a job
there they're making the women that he
harassed apologize to him unlike you
their birthdays yeah ah
hey Fergie get me that get me the Don
Lemon the birthday cake three recent
thing that happened where the girl that
accused that accused him of being a dick
he had to do a second with her yeah the
woman that he got suspended over
oh [__] so there you go Chris let's get
after it and do me a favor Chris why
don't you put a sticker on your show to
make it a little more cool
you [__] Wanna Be hack piece of [__]
get out of here yeah if stickers made
you cool then why aren't you covered in
them you should look like a NASCAR
driver yeah you should look like me when
I used to buy those [__] fake tattoos
and I was like you know eight or nine
how's that Chris how those books that
you've never read behind you what
happened
stupid [__]
ah
but no but I mean he's a nice guy
great guy okay race in America oh this
is gonna be good this is gonna be good
hold on
hey Chris name is Phil I know you talk a
lot about being Italian and I get it you
and I
I both have a hyper vigilance about what
is said what has formed us and it's
funny how yes Huckabee is a Brandon
Shabbos of new people
black woman is Robert De Niro calling
as an Italian married to a movie can you
give me any sort of like advice
you deal with their tempers and I mean
that's coming from an Italian
yo hey why is my spaghetti always have
Tabasco sauce on it now I don't [__]
like it
being in a
yes I know exactly where you're going
with this it's a it's a funny thing
because you know my grandfather keeps
calling it the n-word he did it on
Thanksgiving it was real awkward well we
live in a culture that's pretty
judgmental at times and it makes you
hyper Vigilant to the fact that you see
it outside Chris replies first off thank
you for the call secondly I would never
date a black woman all right that'll be
the death of my mom are you kidding me
yeah my mother would drop dead that day
how old we live in and I pick it up a
lot and of course everyone says oh
there's no such thing as racism no no no
by the way there Islington is racism
the thing that we've always been pushed
pushing on this show is not that racism
doesn't exist it's that we're all
[__] racist and guilty of it and the
single out there pretend it's only one
set of people doing it is ridiculous
um yes there is it's gotten a lot better
of course but it's still there and yeah
because you I'm sorry they get 80 year
old Nona doesn't [__] accept the
black woman because she was born in the
[__] 30s you know what I mean
bashing so I guess my question is my
wife gave me the n-word pass is it okay
if I use it
uh I would only recommend using it in
bed okay that's just my advice to you
but in a sense of being aware about how
the rooms I mean you got to admit like
the role play would be fun dangers when
you walk in okay we're playing we're
playing escape slaying role play okay
well yes
oh Valerie thanks for the laugh guys
thank you for the ten dollars
not in a hateful way but in do a lot of
people know how to talk to each other
whites and blacks he's trying to talk
about even though him trying to not be
racist Italian Guys and you don't grab
me wrong always sound racist when they
talk about race there's no way for them
not to the whites and the blacks
do we know how it's just to hit blacks
with a hard B you know how to just be
ourselves
and realize that we are just all the
same I listen to him no we're not you
know according to the FBI and phrenology
hey buddy keep it up keep up the good
work I love what you're doing take care
um look
I appreciate the call I appreciate the
insight and I think you have some
powerful perspective there
um
I do believe that there is a reason
I not that I agree with it but it's or
that I like it but there is a reason
We Fear The Unknown
I hate you he he this dumb Guido the
thing with Chris and I think the reason
he's this dumb ways that's always why
I've been obsessed with me dumb people
trying to find meaning is one of my
favorite things it's one of my favorite
like
categories of people in this world is
just dumb idiot adiq man what's up into
[__] what's up in the Stars shut up
stop stop
just stop thinking that high concept
Chris
you ever been on like you know you ever
wonder about this uh this crazy Blue
Marble we call Earth
yeah I mean
Chris you're not going to figure out the
secrets to the universe any more than
I'm ever going to capably be able to
make a souffle hey you know the other
day some things in life you go nah not
even gonna bother the other day I was
like what's gravity what's that about
it's like you know it's just unseen
thing but it holds you down
kind of like the weight of being a
[__] but being the brother to Andrew
he never shows up to dinner but he
always holding me down
uh animals tend to keep to their own
kind now you can say well we are all the
same oh oh you're calling animals this
black wife yo Chris why don't you
[__] first of all apologize
now Chris first off you should be knife
to his black wife because the black
people are the ones who started the
stickers on the Hat Thing the thing you
think is so cool and funny okay Chris
this is how I just heard it the guy said
you know man we gotta overcome racism in
this country you know my wife's black
and you know we get a lot of weird
stairs and you went right into well you
know animals can be uh you know
complicated
these banana people hey Chris calm down
humankind
color
Creed
Creed two Creeks this is awful yeah
sure these are dividing lies
um some would argue they were created
for those reasons who created and who
created the bag Chris
who created this I can tell you some
things about my old bosses
they can be barriers to entry for people
now
here's what I'll say I do think that
there's a difference between somebody
who
has animus
and somebody who has what does Animus
mean explain to me and it's like a
Japanese cartoon that's not like big
eyes that's anime karate
stuff like that that's anime Chris this
anime
there's an unfamiliarity
or a basis of ignorance and they should
be judged differently somebody who's
just never been around people who are
different than they are based on
whatever uh identifier you want to use
it can be just organically difficult for
them
um they may have preconceived notions
and you know implicit biases as they say
that make it hard for them to relate and
that's okay because you can learn your
way out of that and you have another
yeah
man okay go ahead yes please
um
you're a [__] idiot all right I'm
sorry but it's funny merch and I hit the
merchandise the saturation point of him
at the same time I was gonna go Chris
shut the [__] up why are you [__]
talking you're a [__] [__] dude
you're so dumb Chris Chris you have to
know how stupid you sound it's important
to me that you know how well don't Guido
you sound like I will say this Chris
to be
how do I put this
but the media right the people that do
what you used to do for a living media
media types they are the least
interesting
dumbest people on the [__] planet the
most vapid people with absolutely no
substance to them
you somehow managed to stand out in that
pack
how did you out stupid them Chris how
did you do it how did you out stupid
them
well you see my my my mother oh no used
to tell me I'm the smartest boy in the
world my mother my mother
your mother's still alive Chris why are
you crying don't put imagine being like
like Chris do you understand it's okay
it's okay Christopher
bro to be so good now
and so dumb and it's so uninteresting
but enough about vert but enough about
Virgie but like and you're a member of
the media you understand that's like
being the rapiest most violent running
yeah ever like that's like going wow
this guy's violent even for the NFL yeah